d'abord donc cette annonce qui fait déjà
couler beaucoup d'encre elle a été faite
par nicolas sarkozy hier soir au conseil
représentatif des institutions juives de
france le crif dès la rentrée prochaine
chaque élève de cm2 se verra confier la
mémoire d'un enfant victime de la shoah
il s'agit de sensibiliser davantage les
jeunes au génocide
mais l'idée fait débat on va s'y arrêter
d'abord le détail de cette proposition
alexandre kara c'est une institution
chaque année le dîner du crif réuni
politiques et religieux pour une soirée
à l'oecuménisme très républicain invité
d'honneur nicolas sarkozy tous
l'attendaient sur la laïcité mais c'est
sur le devoir de mémoire qu'il surprend
son auditoire
j'ai demandé au gouvernement de faire en
sorte que désormais chaque année à
partir de la rentrée scolaire 2008
tous les enfants de cm2 se voit confier
la mémoire d'un des onze mille enfants
français victimes de la shoah rien n'est
plus intime que le nom et le prénom
d'une personne et rien ne touchent
autant un enfant que l'histoire d'un
autre enfant de son âge qui avaient les
mêmes jeux les mêmes joies et les mêmes
espérances que lui autrement dit dès la
rentrée prochaine chaque élève de cm2 à
prendre à l'histoire d'un enfant de son
âge mort en déportation
une histoire nominative et individualisé
qui concernera près de huit cent mille
élèves une mesure dans la lignée de la
lettre de guy môquet qui provoque déjà
un débat dans le monde politique et
éducatif
alors pour